I was supreme optimist my big concern is
that the this period of reset of the
world too much protectionism is building
up among the developed world and that
protectionism is very dangerous and that
protection is also building up among
services which is the next emerging flow
of trade because sixty percent of the
world's services forty percent of the
worldís products and agriculture or
industry and agriculture if if the
developed world starts putting
restrictions on flow services the
developing world which has power of
economics and power of consumption
markets will put restrictions on flow of
products and that's very simple to be
but all you have to do is rate is import
tariffs which have fallen on a
systematic basis over the past 10 15
years so you trigger a war of less trade
I think that would be the most
regressive thing when the developed
world could be doing